[Music]
stormy webster's got her daddy travis
scott's lyrics down packed i love it the
four-year-old totally nails lip syncing
to the rapper's song mamacita with her
very own mamacita kylie jenner
[Music]
they're pretty spot-on right
now it's no surprise stormy is a pro at
lip-syncing that song
she's proven in the past she's a big fan
of it
oh and before that adorable moment
stormy got a special shout out from her
dad on stage
[Music]
[Applause]
but one family member missing from all
the fun kylie and travis's six-month-old
son baby number two
congratulations thank you
so far the two are keeping the little
guy out of the spotlight his name and
face also have yet to be revealed
we have we have some um
we have some
really strong options but we haven't
officially changed it we have some
placeholders so before i officially
change that i just want to be sure
you're seeing that little personality
and as far as how life is going with two
kiddos under their roof now
the source told et the couple is doing
fantastic
things between kylie and travis are
going super well they have really
mastered being together and successfully
co-parenting it's really working for
them and they are just living life
i think it's so good and on top of that
our source also adds travis is very
involved as a father and kylie loves
that
he is always going above and beyond as a
dad and as a partner and kylie
appreciates his dedication to her and
their little ones
[Music]
you